[Applaudissements]
elle ne veut pas entendre une mouche
voler le roi de la triche est de retour
et il faut 7 6 x 57 x sec 49 et il est
la concurrence qu'elle et l'imparfait du
subjonctif du verbe avoir que juste que
tu ce qui lui ont redit qu'ils y
travaillent sont allés pourquoi vous
portez un col roulé par ce beau temps
j'en étais sûr changera jamais sa
mission ça pour tâcher condamné alors
oui sauver son école
j'ai une immense nouvelle pour toi tu
veux remporter une jolie cagnotte pour
ton école
or ce soir
inscris toi au mini conservatoire et
chante comme une casserole mais je
triche quant à roy ça va être la triche
du siet bienvenue dans le temple de la
crise à partir de maintenant on est les
frères au delà ce chat
je te donne mes notes je te donne mes
mots auraient sauvé ducobu change
d'école ducobu va sauver saint potache
votre fils est un génie en crever non au
chaud ce n'est pas maître gims mais faut
avouer qu'il a un joli petit brin de
voix mon pote vous devez le chouchouter
le fouta et humiliations
je ne sais pas comment il fait
il triche
ducobu toi enfin si je sens quelques
salmigondis je serai impitoyable
implacable féroce tout en restant dans
les limites des lois de la république le
5 février au cinéma